I'm glad to be joined today by Ray
Paletta who's the space editor at
inverse she's been investigating goop
products which we've spoken about a
little bit as well as the Wellness
sphere for the last few years I'm super
interested in this Ray I mean let's
start with goop which is a website that
Gwyneth Paltrow is involved with we've
talked about everything from vaginal
steaming which is horrifying and
incredibly dangerous to all sorts of
other pseudoscience products stickers
and and other things that are marketed
on the website how did goop first get
onto your radar so I first started
investigating goop when I was a writer
at Gizmodo
but I had known about it before that
hoop is kind of just being in the public
consciousness unfortunately for a few
years now mostly because they tend to do
these kinds of outlandish product
promotions on their website like many of
the ones that you just named and as
somebody who is a woman and feels that
you know women are particularly targeted
by this kind of pseudo scientific
promotion that it was just personally
something I'm invested in and I felt
like it was something that was worth
digging into so do you know much about
sort of what the relationship is between
some of these companies that advertise
on goop and Gwyneth Paltrow because when
if Paltrow is associated with goop and
of course goop is advertising products
from other companies they aren't
products by goop necessarily are these
standard ad deals in your experience are
they commissioned in some way does
Gwyneth Paltrow benefit beyond just the
fact that her website is selling ads do
we know so it's actually been unclear
what the relationship is well we know
now and from especially my last
investigation which I've done a space
editor at inverse I think what I found
is that they get away with it by saying
that these are not promotions that
rather they're just things they're
obsessed with I think that's the word or
the phrasing that they use they tend to
promote though a lot of the same
characters most recently in my
investigation into Anthony Williams one
of the medical mediums
GUP says is a trusted expert on their
site it just seems that they have some
kind of deal worked out maybe but it's
not one that they've publicly commented
on and if I recall correctly some of
these the regulations around what sorts
of claims you're allowed to make are
different in different countries so for
example in the United States and Canada
they're not the exact same regulations
and what we're finding are that some of
these advertisers that are advertising
on the GUP website they've had problems
in other places including Canada because
of the unsubstantiated health claims
that they make that's correct
and one of the things that troubles me a
lot about our regulations here is as you
know the FDA doesn't have to approve
supplements and that's something that GU
promotes heavily on their website in the
form of vitamin supplements that they
seem to have such as the high school
genes pack that coop sells under their
brand and other you know just various
vitamins that supplements that don't
really need to be approved obviously we
don't know what the safety of these
supplements is so that's a bit
disconcerting what do you think is going
on sort of socio-culturally that is
creating an environment where these
types of scam products can be successful
in the marketplace my idea is that it
starts often from sort of a reasonable
place which is a healthy skepticism of
Big Pharma and sort of like the
advertising industrial complex and that
some people sort of take it too far
and that makes it so that they almost
find anything that the FDA hasn't
endorsed hey if the FDA is terrible so
if they've not endorsed it maybe that's
something I should look into and it's
sort of this desire to do something that
I think is really good which is just
have a healthy level of skepticism about
the world around us that goes too far in
some sense do you agree with that what
else do you think is going on that makes
this type of stuff popular I think that
absolutely taps into what's going on
here David I think that there is this
kind of messaging and group and very
smartly so that people feel that they've
been failed by the pharmaceutical
companies they feel failed by
traditional
and what goop does it's a kind of you
know predatory way sees people who are
six these people who are desperate sees
people who are set up kind of with big
pharma what-have-you and says hey we're
an alternative we can be a solution to
you even though as we've seen time and
again these products don't actually help
anybody in fact in many cases endanger
them more especially in the case of
things like as you said vaginal steaming
yoni eggs you know these are products
that specifically target people people
who are no female identified and that's
really a problem I think that that for
me is one of the most personally
disturbing things that group seems to be
targeting women who are more often than
not failed by traditional medicine and
happened to actually if you will get
research they weighed in emergency rooms
longer than men they're more likely to
report higher instances of pain but get
less treatment for that so women have
legitimate things to be upset about with
regard to the medical industry but goop
is far from some kind of empowering or
even helpful resource for them nobody
can be empowered by false information
and it's disgusting and it's horrifying
that it's being targeted and basically
packaged toward women's way to a much
less damaging degree there's been a
similar dynamic with with diets in in
the West in a sense and what I mean by
that is we all probably have friends on
Facebook who report you know I changed
my diet in this way or that way or I
started drinking three glasses of water
at 10:15 a.m. every morning or whatever
and all of a sudden all of these
different problems have kind of resolved
and I think that there's a significant
sort of self selection bias in that
combined with placebo effect where
there's a lot of people who are
struggling with something and really
what they need is some kind of change in
their life so whether it's going gluten
free or only eating tree nuts for three
months or whatever it is right they were
going to have assuming that they don't
endanger themselves they were going to
report some positive outcomes because
it's a matter of sort of feeling like
they're doing something for themselves
the problem I have with some of the
products you've been following is that
they can straight up do physical
damage they can do physiological damage
to people that can be irreversible or at
least could require significant medical
treatment and that's where any placebo
benefits sort of I I imagined would
completely be counteracted by the actual
physical dangers would they not
absolutely I mean just in my most recent
investigation again into one of groups
medical mediums as a space editor at
inverse I was horrified when I started
researching what Anthony Williams the
medical medium is actually promoting in
his books which are Amazon bestsellers
they have tons of copies countless
copies and have a real cult following
online I was horrified by some of the
advice that he was giving people some of
it involves you know completely changing
your diet only eating one kind of fruit
he's told some of his people that he's
consulted with that's really horrible
for your digestive system I don't know
who or on what plane of reality that
seems maybe he's an advice that you
should give to somebody you know making
these radical changes to your body
system and not expecting any of the
repercussions is just horrifying and
then again what really bothers me a lot
is that goop will put disclaimers on
their website that say you know none of
this is actually approved by the FDA
none of this should substitute medical
advice but did they go on to call these
people trusted experts they go on to
explicitly refer to these people as you
know as such and I think that that's
incredibly irresponsible just flat-out
dangerous you know can you give our
audience a sense of it doesn't have to
be from goop but in all your research of
this Wellness sphere a couple examples
of things that are basically completely
benign but insanely overpriced like they
just they just don't do anything but
they're being sold at outrageous prices
and then on the other hand a couple
examples of like the really dangerous
stuff things I noticed that this hasn't
even been surveyed goop so one of the
things that I thought was really funny
that goop has been had promoted last
year
I did investigation on was these $120
body vibes stickers I believe they were
called they were literally just stickers
like the ones that I think I got back in
the 90s from the grocery store or
whatever but you'd allegedly put them on
your body and they would heal you in all
sorts of ways they would heal your
anxiety they could heal physical damage
you know all sorts of outlandish claims
again these were $120 stickers for a
pack that one is just you know it's
ultimately benign because it's you know
it's not actually going to hurt anyone I
guess it's hurting their wallets and
maybe you would help yourself esteem her
yourself esteem you rather when you
think about how much money you pay your
stickers but it's not actually gonna
cause you any damage I'm seeing other
things from the Wellness Fair lately you
know just different riffs on old dieting
tricks so for example I saw the other
day at the store something called
I love my skinny body tea and this is
something I have a particular issue with
because it's using various plans and FDA
you know on MTA regulated information to
promote this kind of detoxifying key
that's a word we see a lot now there's
no evidence that this key is going to
make you lose weight and also why do we
keep messaging to people that the
ultimate goal in their lives should be
to lose weight anyway that's a different
conversation but I mean this he just
basically is a combination of cinnamon
and some vanilla chocolate flavorings
that's not going to do anything it's
just funny to see unleash the model
within I don't know maybe it would just
be releasing sadness with him because
you're paying like six or five dollars
per bottle of Teebs ridiculous but I
guess yeah going on to the more
dangerous stuff you know when we see
things like those a gional scheming
that's being promoted on I mean that
just is a nightmare the the yummy eggs
that are produced with materials that
are definitely not safe for people to be
inserting into their vaginas these are
things that are okay with goop but not
for you know it's terrible for Public
Health the thing I also want to mention
I have a particular issue with is group
using what I called medicine bags to
heal people of various ailments one of
the things they promote is carnelian
stone to treat infertility and I think
that is very harmful in a psychological
way for a lot of women who are
struggling to get pregnant and
infertility is a big issue in their
lives and then saying oh well if you
just get this stone you know you can
have a better chance at becoming
pregnant I think that's incredibly
manipulative and predatory yeah and
sometimes even the ones like for example
there might be no harm in standing near
a stone or I don't know what you're
supposed to do with it maybe it's more
than standing near it but anything
you're doing that has no impact that's
going to delay you from seeking actual
help with that could actually end up
specifically when it's something like
having a baby you might end up just
losing several years that you could have
actually been working with a medical
professional because you're trying out
rocks or whatever else yes is that it
basically tells people that they don't
need to seek actual medical advice for
some of their problems this is something
that I talked about with some of my
friends including dr. Jenna Gunter who's
done a lot of great working this year as
well and has been a critic against of
goop and you know she and I were talking
one time and we were saying that
basically when you follow the advice of
some of these people including the
medical medium that people believe that
you know maybe when when he makes claims
that cancer and other disease or not
genetic then you can fix it by eating
fruits and vegetables I mean that's just
a flat-out lie and it's not just a lie
it's actually a dangerous high
so this is actually delaying people from
getting screened for various illnesses
you know going into their families
history and seeing if they have genetic
predispositions to any of these problems
it's really dangerous and frankly all I
can say is that I'm just disgusted by it
but I don't I just don't really know how
these people sleep at night frankly yeah
no III agree with you there we've been
speaking with rape a letter she's been
investigating the Wellness sphere as
well as specifically products available
on Gwyneth Paltrow's goop website space
editor at inverse thanks so much for
talking to about this to us about this
thanks for having me on